samedi 23 septembre les jardins
familiaux de guyancourt se sont
agrandies
[Musique]
il s'agit là de l'inauguration de
l'extension des jardins familiaux de
guyancourt avec trente et une nouvelle
parcelle qui ont été mises à côté du
jardin existant et qui donc permettent
de pérenniser cette installation est
d'offrir à au plus grand nombre
officiellement loué depuis juin dernier
ces nouvelles parcelles de 170 à 200
mètres carrés vont permettre aux
locataires de laisser libre cours à leur
créativité de jardiniers en herbe je
demande conseil aux anciens qui qui me
donne pas mal de conseils il faut
planter sa à telle période ça à telle
période et voilà à quoi bon là je me
suis lancé déjà dans dans la salade
alors vous avez du talent
par contre les choux je me suis mangé
les shows par les oiseaux
j'aurais dû les recouvrir l'association
des jardins familiaux de guyancourt
compte aujourd'hui 91 membres pour le
plus grand plaisir de son président nous
ce qu'on aime justement cette contact
voire tous les membres de l'association
se croiser pouvoir discuter déchets buts
et chouchouter les jardins sont loin de
là c'est les foules puisque déjà 20
cents personnes sont sur liste
d'attentes